Facebook taking steps to enforce its
hate speech policies now permanently
banning controversial figures and some
organizations among the high-profile
voices that the social media giant
considers quote dangerous here we go
Nation of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan
Infowars host Alex Jones and
conservative writer Melo unitless the
company's CEO Mark Zuckerberg saying the
ban also extends to other platforms
including Instagram so Emily what
strikes me here is I think lots of
people wonder is this in defiance of
your First Amendment rights or is it the
case that since Facebook's not the
government a private business they have
the right to stand up and say hey you
know what you've incited violence and
whatever our standards are you violated
them and you're gone they are a private
company they are not a government entity
which means that yes they can set their
own sensory and rules and policies by
which they can abide I think this is a
total first I think this is an exercise
by Facebook and Zuckerberg to make us
think that they care and that they're
virtuous and that they're concerned or
whatever and really it's distracting us
from the reality that they are and it is
a platform that amplifies violence and I
think it's it's impossible to reconcile
how all of a sudden they feel
responsible for this content by
right-wingers and you know one on the
left or whatever and all of a sudden
they're shutting it down when they have
refused every step of the way to take
responsibility for their platform that
livestreams gang rapes and suicides and
terrorist recruitment and show up in
court constantly ads oh no no no we're
not responsible for the content and
here's why we have nothing novel and all
of a sudden they care about this so if I
was one of the attorneys that has
brought a negligence lawsuit against
them or a representative that is
drafting questions for the congressional
inquiry I would ask how all the sudden
they feel responsible for this content
and not their content as a platform as a
whole you know in fact Jesse lots of
people I'm surprised I'm looking at the
poll numbers people think you know what
Facebook in these other social media
sites they just foam and hate and and
they are not to be trusted it's it's
kind of shocking Emily's honest on that
a lot of people have just lost faith in
well if you don't like someone on
Facebook don't follow them it's not that
hard to figure out and I think you're
right I think this was a PR move to say
we got it under control but there's also
guys on CNN that spend their whole day
calling Facebook and saying can you ban
this person can you please ban this
person it's pretty pathetic if you work
for a media company you're supposed to
be all about free speech to spend your
whole day on the phone trying to shut
other people's free speech to help me
that's there I don't know what you're
talking for respondents on multiple
networks that call social media
companies and try to get other people
thrown off you know what that's what you
know I know why it's political but it's
my thing is this I think they shouldn't
ban anybody I think they should have
Farrakhan I think they should have
everybody more freedom is better than
less freedom unless they're actually
inciting violence I think Facebook
private company knock them out but once
we get into nitpicking who we're gonna
kick off I think it's a slippery slope
well Kennedy here's a here's here's a
proposition do you think that we as
Americans as American society are better
off without these provocateurs these
voices of incitement being there in
facebook Instagram where most Americans
now get their news if you're beholding
to big personalities on social media you
get a lot bigger problem then then
someone needing to be banned and I I
don't think that this really does
anything it doesn't make the world any
safer and this notion that that we have
to be insulated from ideas that we
disagree with or things we find
offensive that our entire lives have to
be bubble-wrapped
it's actually really dangerous because
at some point an entire generation of
people who've been bubble-wrapped and
sanitized their whole lives they're
gonna be running everything and they're
gonna be a bunch of cream puffs and and
I'm kind of terrified for at that point
and I do think that I I share Snoop
Dogg's frustration because I know that
he was really upset that Minister
Farrakhan was thrown off of Facebook and
the Graham Minister that's that's what
it calls very respectful respectful and
you know I I don't think this does
anything I don't think it changes
people's beliefs I don't think sanitized
makes it better and I agree with Emily I
think it's just a way cuz Mark
Zuckerberg or Joel Sandberg has spent so
much time in front of Congress apologize
we're so sorry we're gonna do better
we're gonna do so much better and this
just makes it look like they're doing
something you know what I know it is
great and I'm really interested in
hearing what you think about this I saw
the other day that the New Zealand
shooters horrific slaughter is still on
some sites that you can still get up
there and see it and to me this then
contributes to radicalization of some
people who like this guy who just shot
the synagogue up outside of San Diego
and he cited it and so I do think it
makes a difference if our social media
perpetrates hate speech allows groups to
form that you know like Isis and alike
who are have radical extremist ideology
I don't think it's good what do you
think well I mean I do believe that this
is nothing more than a virtue signal
that's all it is and and I would be a
hypocrite if I condemned Facebook for
this because I always say that social
media with I would be good to be thrown
off social media get it out of my life I
hate it but it does seem like they're
more easily inclined to police one side
of the nutcases and not the others and I
noticed on other media arenas they were
they were portraying Farrakhan as
far-right Washington Post yeah which I
which which I believe in in the media's
world there's no such thing as far left
because they're within that world and
they don't believe there's a far left
everything that's unusual or extremist
is far right but I have to say this you
got to be where it's really cool to be
labeled dangerous and if somebody banned
me and said I because I was dangerous I
mean rock and roll what's called
dangerous so they gotta be careful like
a lot of times people get attention by
being bad it obviously would help out
exactly exactly
but I mean Facebook they banned
extremists the Dems just elect them if
you look at Booker T Washington market
Garvey I think for Eric on saying that
tradition is interesting to have a
conversation yeah I don't know he's
definitely a that's what I would do
that's not the issue the issue was
whether or not these organ at news
organizations that said he's a
conservative right we're whether they
were wrong that was more they issued a
correction
well yeah but I just think you know what
look back look at him intern
a black American life and thought he's a
conservative on somebody she's an
anti-semite that's why he doesn't like
gays are you to say he's anti-semitic
that's the better point what he says
about Jewish people